what
um
yeah
what's up
for me
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
good morning everyone please take your
seats we are starting our meeting
and I just want to warn you that I will
speak Polish so take your headphones
since it's the most beautiful language
in the world
easy to learn if you're wishing
ready
off we go
dear guests dear speakers dear
participants
I'm truly honored to open our
interparliamentary committee meeting of
the uh
committee on women's rights
that we are organizing on the occasion
of the of international women's day in
this year and I have to tell you that we
missed you because our recent meetings
were remote
uh this year our meeting will be devoted
to gender aspects of energy poverty
we are very pleased and I would like to
point out that
we do have so many
members from 16 EU National parliaments
attending but also colleagues from the
European Parliament
and I am very pleased to welcome you all
on this very important occasion and we
will
have a great pleasure listening to your
contributions in our debate and
in this debate on energy poverty which
is a phenomenon that affects all our
countries
before we
uh proceed to the debate I will have a
few technical announcements this event
is organized in collaboration with the
directorate for relations with national
parliaments uh welcome to the
representatives of this directorate we
have interpretation available in all EU
languages you can listen to me in all
your languages and also the meeting is
web streamed so
the entire world can watch us
please behave
and also please note that time for
interventions is really limited so there
will be a clock displayed throughout the
event which will be visible behind me so
we can monitor the time of interventions
in order to ask the floor members of
national parliaments need to fill in the
speaking card and once they've been
given the floor they have to press the
speak button
no
to today's issue of gender aspects of
energy poverty
I think
we are all aware
of the fears
of the challenges that we are facing in
the context of the ever worsening
economical situation on our continent
the EU is facing a growing and a
persistent uh
challenge
of actual energy poverty
estimates say that uh
about 125 million citizens of the EU are
affected
since 2021 the energy shortage has led
to inflation in Eurozone reaching its
highest level in history
first the covid-19 crisis then the
crisis resulting from the Russian war in
Ukraine have exacerbated the economic
and social difficulties many people in
Europe were already facing and in
particular as usual with all crises
women
many households on our continent
struggle to afford the rising costs of
energy and to keep their homes
adequately heated I'd like to remind you
that even before the war broke out seven
percent of EU households were not able
to pay their bills
six percent
could not sufficiently heat their homes
so you have to imagine the situation now
those who are most vulnerable
we know that single mothers and single
women are more likely than men to
struggle with paying energy bills
around half of single mothers
and about one-third of single women
are among those
having
largest difficulties in this area
the reasons for this are well known
many women have lower average incomes
they work part-time they also work in a
low paid or precarious forms of
employment
many women do not own
their home their apartment they are
dependent on their husband partner
economically
and also many women work without pay for
example in the household
so as with the pandemic crisis the
consequences of energy prices on
individuals and small businesses but
also de-industrialization unemployment
and recession are disproportionately
affecting women because of their already
lower participation in the labor market
and existing gender gaps in many sectors
we will probably hear about that from
our experts today
this cost of living crisis negatively
impacts women's economic and social
inclusion their health risk of domestic
violence and their fundamental rights
so this
makes it harder for women with low or no
income to escape abuse and domestic
violence from a partner to whom they are
as I just mentioned also financially
tied
we can also observe that many women are
reporting being forced to give up
medical care more often due to Rising
costs to longer waiting times and
shortages of doctors and medication
around one-third of people say they have
given up on treatment in 2022.
one-third
over the past few years
our committee
has taken various steps to address this
pressing issue
in 2022
the farm committee adopted an opinion on
the proposal for a directive on Energy
Efficiency and called for a specific
measures to
combat the feminization of energy
poverty
it also provided guidelines and requests
that gender be mainstreamed into the
energy transition
the same year if I'm committee carried
out a report on women poverty in Europe
which calls on the EU and its member
states to integrate a gender perspective
into policies and practices addressing
the lack of access to Affordable and
adequate housing and energy
I would just like to remind you that the
EU does not have a common definition of
energy poverty
and the report we also urge to develop
uh specific strategies aimed at
eradicating these problems by 2030 and
ensuring that Services effectively meet
the needs of homeless women
I do hope that this interparliamentary
committee meeting on the occasion of
international women's day
will explore ways in which gender
equality requirements can be integrated
into policies and initiatives at the EU
national and local levels in order to
alleviate the energy poverty problem
so now I would like to give the floor to
our
great vice president of European
Parliament a great friend of our
committee who
is always here when we invite him as
always a man who is very involved in the
fight for gender equality and women's
rights
I think we both believe that there is a
special place reserved in hell for women
who do not for men who do not support
women sorry so I would like now to ask
the vice president of the Union
Parliament to uh deliver the opening
remarks for our historic
interpolimentary committee meeting
Demetrius are probably in your mother
tongue you have the floor
to give you the possibility to compare
if the Polish of the Greek are
attractive and
easy to be learned
so I should like to thank you for the
invitation and I'd like to congratulate
the farm committee
as well as its president Mr Robert
piedron
for deciding to celebrate the women's
day by discussing a very pressing issue
by and to avoid General discussions the
pressing issue is how does energy crisis
affect the equality gender equality goal
this pre-existed the Putin's Invasion
into Ukraine but it has become
worse ever since
Robert said gave a few figures the truth
is that the already
existing inequalities
against the poorer households the poorer
people and
women as well as the younger and older
citizens which pre-existed
have been integrated into this crisis
and have now become worse half
single women last year before Putin's
Invasion were diff had difficulty in
heating up their houses and pay their
bills and poorer families
who had
older houses or
poorly built houses poorly insulated
houses had to spend more energy
in order to heat them
Robert mentioned
120 million
that according to eurostat are already
below the poverty line well this number
has risen already and among them the
majority is women
in single parent families the vast
majority are women
and unmarried mothers
and
during the crisis
a number of businesses
which needed to deal with the inflation
with the supply chain crisis
increased the pay gap between men and
women
and since women
are mostly working in
precarious jobs the ratio between men
and women is even worse as regards safe
jobs and that is how the Gap worsened so
the question for us
the European
legislators is what do we do about it do
we just record the figures no this is
the job of eurostat not of the European
Parliament our job is to see what we can
do in order to
decrease the inequalities and what we
cannot do all together what we can do
all together at a European
level what is what each member State
doing individually enough well the
situation tells us facts tell us that it
is not enough because there are
larger countries that have a larger
margins to support their vulnerable
households and businesses and women but
what does Europe do is does the European
Union do what they can do so as the
president of the high level group for
gender equality which the majority of
which are women and who have made me the
honor of
making me the president for the last
nine years
I say that Europe doesn't is not doing
enough and I also say as a member of the
budget Committee Member where I need to
go immediately because their meeting
started at nine o'clock and are
discussing important issues anyway and
just like in view in order to deal with
the pandemic we set up a
a tool the Next Generation EU the rrf
for the Recovery Fund these are
technical terms anyway the techn the
European commission the European Union
has
got from the banks 750 million Europe in
North Euros in order to deal with a
crisis and create new tools this is what
we have to do regarding the gender
issues not to scrape the bottom of the
Barrel in order to see what has been
left over from other policies in order
to deal with that it is impossible for
us to deal with this
Social Challenges that make gender
equality much much worse with a budget
an EU budget of the order of one percent
of the total and the gender Dimension
social and gender equality Dimension
should not be left out horizontally
uh
and not be mainstreamed in every policy
and every program some steps have been
taken in the budget of 2023 regarding
some pilot projects this is not enough
we need to set up new instruments as
well as to increase the
EU budget in the medium term because we
have already exhausted the reserves or
reserves of the MMF and up until 2027
and in order to avoid the uh the
dispute between the net contributors and
net receivers which leads to a bad
situation we need to increase the own
resources of the Union on the basis of
the agreement between commission and
Council we cannot deal this with this
crisis with one percent of EU GDP at the
point
when the
corresponding budget in the U.S is 20 if
we don't do more on the on equality
issues at the European level we are
going to be faced with a serious problem
and populist
anti-european
ultra-conservative voices will be
strengthened they exist within the union
and they are against
equality they are in the so-called
traditional approach whereby women
should stay at home and raise their
children so we need to be to do more so
I believe that we this debate is not
only going to recall to register the
facts but we are going to listen to
ideas and proposals about what can be
done in order to improve the situation
and to be able to offer better services
to our citizens especially the more
vulnerable citizens at an EU level
therefore women will be will benefit
because they are the ones who are the
those who lose from this situation
we just want to look at the monthly Euro
barometer whereby the vast majority of
our citizens require specific things and
the European Parliament is much closer
to these wishes aspirations and requests
inside the council where the we the
government Representatives sit we see
selfishness and nationalist prejudices
they say why can we why do we need to do
something altogether if I am able to
deal with my situation in my country no
but there is a gap and the Gap is being
filled by Voices saying that the
European Union has failed we need to go
back to the nation state so those of us
who which are better and
higher more those of us which for more
Europe we need to work
to strive for the European Union to have
more means to fight inequalities to move
away
from this
very common place too little too late
which is a characteristic of what we do
there's not we don't have much time I
believe that in the coming year up until
the next European elections we showed
uh walk faster
the European Parliament is willing to
proceed the European commission making
some
proposals but the big problem lies with
the governments which discuss and
discuss and discuss and postpone and
postpone and let me give you a ancient
Greek
expression
meaning there's no time for further
postponement the time is not right and
for us to in to achieve the global
equality of genders we need 182 years
and for the European Union to achieve
this goal will require more than 60
years according to estimates there is a
history will not
be easy on us if we allow it to happen
thank you
thank you chair
we certainly need to act thank you
for your inspiring provocation as usual
um I hope it will also offer some
solutions as you
um
suggested Solutions which will really
solve actual problems of the citizens of
the European Union thank you once again
and thank you
I know you will have to leave us soon a
meeting but I'm quite sure we shall send
you the summary of our conclusion so
that we can coordinate our work and
combat poverty so thank you very much
once again thank you for your presence
and now time to move to the part where
we shall listen to our experts first the
political part now we have the expert
part and the first person to take the
floor will be a director of you and
women in Brussels Lawrence gilwa
good morning director
I would like just to tell you that you
and women does not need to be introduced
we cooperate not only in European
Parliament but also in member states and
in the EU in general
this organization is very important
however in September last year U.N women
published a document or Global energy
crisis in Access impact on access to
energy and food availability
um
and food security and nutrition I'm
quite sure you will refer to the
document which you have with you
ahead of you and women floors yours
thank you very much chair for the kind
introduction and I I see you broke the
news already thank you very much for the
invitation to join the
inter-parliamentary committee meeting on
the internet on the occasion of
international women's day 2023
excellencies this distinguished
panelists and colleagues it is a
pleasure to join the panel and have the
opportunity to exchange on the
co-benefits of achieving gender equality
and addressing energy or poverty
as you know
gender equality and the empowerment of
all women and girls is Central to the
transition to sustainable energy and
ensuring Universal energy access
as well as progress towards all
sustainable development goals
gender responsive and women-led
initiatives and projects have widely
demonstrated that they can be successful
in the new energy space including
providing sustainable energy solutions
at different levels
women are also increasingly active in
the energy Workforce and we'll hear
about it and as entrepreneurs in micro
small and medium Enterprises
contributing to sustainable and
Industrial Development
women
and girls are agents of change as
consumers
as producers
innovators and decision makers across
the energy sector
yet
women and girls disproportionately
experience energy poverty and are those
who bear the brunt of inequal access to
sustainable affordable and clean energy
sources and this was said in the
introduction
globally
this affects particularly rural women
and girls living in least developed
countries
in the EU
women are also particularly affected by
energy poverty as they represent 85
percent of single parent families as was
said also in the introduction which have
also a particular high risk of child
poverty
this does not only hinder the
development of their full potential and
their enjoyment of a range of Human
Rights including access to education and
right to work but also contributes to
increasing their risk of being exposed
to gender-based violence and reduces the
access to Quality Health Care
moreover
it also contributes to the time poverty
due to the burden of unpaired care and
domestic work that is placed on women
and girls particularly so in rural areas
increasingly the disproportionate impact
of the climate and environmental
emergencies on women's and girls energy
poverty have been compounded by the
consequences of the kovi 19 pandemic and
the war in Ukraine as again was said in
the introduction reversing progress on
the 2030 agenda and on gender equality
soaring costs and of oil and gas due to
the war in Ukraine have had the literous
effects on women's and girls energy
poverty and already unequal access to
energy as highlighted in the study that
was mentioned and the global gendered
impacts of the Ukraine crisis on energy
access and food Security in nutrition
which was published last year in
collaboration with the UN Global crisis
response group
looking now at Solutions because we are
invited to look at Solutions as well a
sustainable energy transition
crucial for climate change mitigation
Environmental Conservation and disaster
risk reduction offers both challenges
and opportunities for the resilience of
women
but address transition can only be
achieved
through the full and equal participation
leadership and decision making of women
and girls
this requires ensuring the voices and
participation of women in all their
diversity are headed both as gender
equality advocates
and as Target groups of policies and
programs within the gender energy Nexus
in fact significant evidence shows that
energy interventions that take into con
account women needs and priorities are
more likely to have a positive impact on
addressing household and Community
energy poverty and on gender equality
more broadly
integrating gender equality perspectives
into renewable energy policy not only
makes sense socially and environmentally
but it also makes good economic sense
in rural context for example
freeing up women's time from unpaired
domestic care work through basic
infrastructure and access to clean
modern energy opens up more time in a
day contributing to local economies
while of course promoting women's
economic empowerment and poverty
alleviation
increasing women's access to decent work
and Leadership of organizations and
companies in the energy sector is
critical not only for gender equality
and women's economic empowerment but
also to enhance efficiency innovation
and sustainability
in renewable energy women make up 32
percent of the renewable energy
Workforce compared to
22 percent in conventional energy but
they are concentrated in lower paying
non-technical positions
women occupy 31 of mean management
positions but are strikingly
underrepresented in senior positions and
in policy making and decision making
gender and desegregated data are needed
to create a more comprehensive
assessment of energy value chains which
not only clarify differences in energy
access but also reveal the often
invisible framework of needs and impacts
that compound iniquities in Access for
underrepresented groups
and as the U.N Secretary General
confirmed no program large or small can
be considered to be sustainable or
contributing to resilience if it
increases rather than decreases the
unpaired care and domestic work of women
and girls
to address these interconnected issues
it is key
to work with multiple and diverse
stakeholders on coordination on policy
and programmatic initiatives
within the EU for example
the social climate fund represents a
great opportunity to ensure the
mainstreaming of gender equality and
equal opportunities tanking into
consideration the specific situation of
women and girls in all their diversity
and in external relations of the EU the
upcoming midterm review of the gender
action plan 3 represents another great
opportunity to look at the interlinkages
between gender equality and the energy
policies globally as well
finally as you may know in a few days
the 67th Commission on the status of
women will start on 6th of March in New
York and we look in depths on the topic
of innovation and technological change
and education in the digital age for
achieving gender equality and the
empowerment of all women and girls
the digital transition represents at the
same time risks and opportunities
and it will be and many actually of
these risks and opportunities intersects
with energy issues so it will be also a
very good moment to link digital
Innovation and addressing the gender
aspects of energy poverty thank you very
much for your attention and I look
forward to the next contributions and to
The Exchange afterwards thank you
thank you very much director for those
inspiring words
we will indeed meet in New York in a few
days
in order to discuss
also in the context of the energy crisis
at the 67th session
of the conference on the stages of women
I think many national parliaments will
also be represented at this session in
New York
so I think there will be another
occasion to deepen our cooperation with
the UN and with you and women in
particular so thank you once again and
congratulations also because you have
been with you and women for quite a
while but you've only recently became
director so congratulations on the new
position and we are keeping our fingers
crossed for you
so our next expert
is Madame Ana De Sosa
who is a civil mechanical and petroleum
engineer at the technical Superior
Institute of Lisbon
she has a huge wealth of experience in
terms of energy production energy
transition
she's been awarded with many prestigious
prizes I don't think we have the time to
enumerate all of those prices and her
great background
but I can tell you that
she was awarded a
prizes for uh
emerging problems in the exploration of
hydrocarbons how to better employ
biomass and how to use water for energy
generation so I wonder who we'll discuss
with her on these topics
Mr Sosa the floor is yours for 10
minutes
[Music]
committee on women's rights and gender
equality members Mr chair Robert biedron
dear tandes and panel colleagues I am
honored to speak with you today about
gender aspects of energy poverty a
critical issue that is affecting many
households across Europe
and particularly impacting women
gender
inequality is a prevalent issue that has
been present
for centuries
and its impacts are felt in all spheres
of our life
one of the most affected sectors is
energy sector
if women have limit access to energy
resources
this leads to a lack of opportunities
and to reduce quality of life
so this issue requires imminent
attention
and as we work towards achieving gender
equality
we must also address the energy poverty
crisis
so what are the solutions to solve this
problem
first of all
my colleague already mentioned
that we need to collect
data
can we go to the previous slide
the previous one
yes
so first of all we need it's too much
so first of all sorry we need to collect
data and already you have mentioned that
we need to collect disaggregated data on
energy uses and access
here is an image of my country and for
instance there are people that currently
are using biomass in rural areas to cook
and this exposed them to harmful smoke
emissions
causing risk respiratory illness
this and energy programs that provide
clean cooking Solutions should Target
women as primary beneficiary
beneficiaries
second
we need to involve women in energy
policy and decision-making processes
despite being extremely affected by
energy poverty women are
underrepresented in energy policy and
decision making
so by engaging women in these processes
we can ensure that their perspectives
and needs are considered
women can provide valuable insights into
the energy sector and help design gender
responsive energy policies that benefit
the entire Society
third in designing energy infrastructure
it is necessary to keep women in mind
so we then
women tend to have different energy
needs than men
designing energy infrastructures that
consider these needs can help to ensure
that women have access to the Energy
Services they require
[Music]
women are most likely to be Caregivers
for children and for elderly family
members this means that they may spend
more time at home and have a greater
need to energy to power household
appliances and consequently have higher
energy bills
so to mitigate this problem providing
measures that ensure that homes are
equipped with energy efficient
appliances will require the amount of
energy needed to power them and help
these caregivers
the next idea is to provide training and
job opportunities to women in the energy
sector
encouraging women to pursue career
careers in the energy sector can help to
address gender disparities
this can can be achieved through
education and vocational training
programs that Target women
the next idea that I want to share with
you is to address this inequity in
access to financial resources
women often have less access to
financial resources than men's which
exacerbates the energy poverty crisis
providing financial assistance that is
accessible
to women
such as through specific Financial
programs or family focused policies can
help to address this issue
foreign
Academy can contribute to build capacity
and raising awareness of energy poverty
by offering training education programs
for policy makers
practitioners and committee members next
slide please this program can help
equip individuals and organizations with
the Knowledge and Skills need to design
and Implement effective energy policies
and programs that prioritize gender
equity and social inclusion
and in next slide we can see that
we can if we can educate communities on
the benefits of gender equality in
energy access we can have better results
in the next slide
we present here an idea if we raise
awareness about the links between gender
equality and energy access
we can help to promote gender response
responsive energy policies and encourage
communities to support the inclusion of
women in energy decision making process
this can be achieved through
community-based programs that Target
women men and Youth
so in the next slide I will
um
give the idea that we if we will we work
together we can solve this problem
and in conclusion gender equality
considerations are critical in
addressing the energy poverty crisis we
must involve women in all stages of
policy and program design processes and
ensure that their perspectives and needs
are considered
governments Civil Society Academia and
the private sector must work together to
create Innovative financing mechanisms
to support Energy Efficiency and
renewable energy projects by working
together as I mentioned we can ensure
that no one is Left Behind and that we
achieve our goal of gender equality and
universal access to Energy Services
thank you
Obrigado thank you very much for your
presentation and thank you for making it
understandable for us since you are such
an expert that I was afraid that we will
not understand but at least I try to
understand it very inspirational
presentation thank you very much for
that
um
next speaker
is
uh
Mrs uh Katarina habers Bruner
who is the co-author of a report on
gender and
energy poverty
developed as part of empowerment and it
focuses on the coastal areas of the
Mediterranean
in order to reduce energy poverty and
increase the health of persons
affected by energy poverty including a
energy poverty and Mrs cyberburner you
have the floor for 10 minutes
thank you very much
attendance the panelists I'm very happy
to be here thanks for organizing this
important event and
I also likes the idea um of the coach
here to look at Solutions and I think we
already have seen Solutions because we
have them and we have to to implement
them and I'm here today as a
representative of women engaged for
common future working on tender trust
Energy Solutions worldwide but also of a
partner of the Consortium of the
empowerment project which works on
energy poverty and is also able to
provide some Solutions in the
Mediterranean countries
next slide should I can I have the
pointer please
Okay so
okay yeah
thank you very much yeah so we already
heard a lot about causes of energy
poverty we know we always say it's
indecent housing it's higher energy
prices it's low income it's true but but
we have seen in the last years also the
fossil fuel dependency and the logins
what we have seen and anyhow what is now
worsening it's a systemic and structural
inequalities and now the energy crisis
uh sees like a spotlight shows like a
spotlight that who is affected by by the
energy crisis who is affected by energy
poverty and I think that is one
important message to work on the
systemic and structural inequalities to
also to face energy poverty and gender
is part of all these courses here on
energy poverty next slide please
have you heard a lot of the data what I
share with you here is a current study
um of oil found and it's um it's very
recent because household has been asked
if they have been able to pay the energy
bill and what we here see over overall
is
um who is mostly affected and maybe not
able to pay the energy bill it's already
it's a low income and vulnerable
households so again the information
again
um the argument that households
vulnerable households being affected by
many problems also facing
um significantly the energy crisis and
are affected by energy poverty and what
we see here also in terms of of gender
that loan parents mostly
um single-led households by women they
are mostly affected by an energy poverty
and here what we see in the graph it is
an economic perspective but energy
poverty does not only have the economic
gender perspective and on the next slide
we see four dimensions we should
consider and we should discuss about
when we talk about energy poverty and
gender because it's
um
because it's it's important to include
them all so we have we have seen the
economic part so the economic part is
because of the gender pay Gap because of
the gender care Gap so women are working
more in the households all over Europe
in the whole world because of such
gender pension Gap so if you have lower
income during your work life span so of
course you have less income as pension
so it's more or less about 60 percent in
Europe so as a gender pension Gap leads
to the economic situations that there
are women has less have less income so
that's one important Dimension but we
also we have some physiological
Dimension because women they are more
heat and cold sensitive because of
physiology because of the body they are
more sensitive to extreme temperatures
and when we talk about energy poverty
now we have March and we talked a lot
about winter energy poverty but in many
countries but not in my country it's a
more moment but I guess we have to face
it we have to talk about summer energy
poverty if you are not able to cool your
home and though things that's very
important and it's also a tender issue
so to have extreme temperatures so also
is this physiological Dimension women
are heated more and we have the health
Dimension and we can distinguish here
mental health physical health and also
social health so we we know on on
physical health we have seen the example
from Portugal so heating for example
with biomass can lead to indoor
pollution we have it in Europe in Our
member states so that women are more
affected women and children we also see
that there is a cardiovascular diseases
from heat is headache for example that's
because of energy poverty and also
mental and social health it's stress
it's depression it's stigmatization
because you are not able to invite
friends because you have a cool or too
hot home for example it's a different
impact for different genders and the
social and cultural Dimension so we we
have our Channel we see our gender roles
we see who is doing secure work in the
households who is facing also time
poverty who is not represented in the
decision-making bodies even if the law
would foresee it because we have quota
so we we would like to have balanced
bodies and decision-making premiums but
things that's also a very important
Dimension to consider and this four
dimensions needs to be considered when
talking about policies when talking
about social policies energy policies
work policies for example that is very
important to see it from this
perspective next slide please and
regarding empowerment it's a project
because here to look at Solutions that's
one concrete Horizon 2020 projects in
the in the Mediterranean country so it's
a focus on gender it's a focus on health
so the health impact of energy poverty
and it's also a focused on energy
poverty and here all the activities all
the measures are coming from
mobilization and capacity buildings or
to provide all the information what we
already have on energy poverty because
we gained information of course we need
more but there is information and there
is knowledge very concrete activities on
household visits on workshops on
Collective assemblies so Collective
assemblies is a concept which is
implemented started in Barcelona it's
for example to invite effect affected
people to develop jointly Solutions so
not to have the asymmetric relationship
between an energy advisor and between
energy poor households but being on the
same level and to to develop skills to
face an energy poverty so that is very
interesting and can be implemented in
many countries so we have pilot sites so
I checked also the participants list and
I think many of you are here so it's
from Albania Croatia France Italy
Slovenia and Spain so here in the
country we already we have some some
solutions we develop recommendations to
take the energy poverty and we do
advocacy and I will also share some
recommendations and idea what we have
next slide
yeah and maybe one point
um Anna mentioned we need more data
that's crucial and there is one studies
from Austria about invisible invisible
energy poverty and see for example a
study from Austria in the cities of Graz
and Vienna shows that there's 40 percent
of unreported cases of energy poverty
because people are they feel affected by
energy poverty through a self-assessment
but it's not
um sufficiently reflected in the static
statistics what we have and it's also
there's a lot of
under consumption and there's the
effects of under consumption for example
can be also social isolation to reject
the support because you think I can
manage it I can cope it so there are for
example at the moment many students are
not suffering on on poverty but not
heating the homes properly because of
the fear of a high energy bill
um it's to feel ashamed for example the
fear of stigmatization so there are many
um outcomes of under consumption so that
also is very important to see how to
collect this data
um of invisible energy next slide
and yeah solution so for example in the
empowerment project or another project
so we Implement and we apply gender
tools and here it's also we have with
igabusion women with many we have many
experts here today so we have such
gender tools we can Implement and it's
from tender analysis just to have a
baseline where we come from for example
there are many tools and I would like to
focus on two what we do mainly in the
empowerment project the first one is
communication I think I repeat it all
the time but with a gender just
communication we really we can have
quick wins so to to put more effort and
attention on our language on the
pictures what we use because we see so
many stereotypes and we reinforce
inequalities with our communication and
also the energy sector which is very
male dominated so here we can improve a
lot in short time to use gender trust
communication tools and of course it's
policy and advocacy so to develop uh
policy recommendation for gender trust
energy in Social policies to include the
experts for example and also to have an
energy poverty definition or a concept
including gender and vulnerable
households and finally on the next slide
I come to the recommendations and the
idea and it's a broad Bunch from very
general recommendations uh in very
specific one so the first one of course
we have seen it's a broad topic so we
need another policy designed to reshape
our policy and to have a cross-sectoral
coherent strategy to include feminist
organizations as political advisors to
have the right for everybody for all to
clean affordable energy for all and to
have inclusion and affordable
accessibility at the Forefront so that's
very general the second already
mentioned by Anna it's data collection
and also definitions on EU and National
level so and to include tender for
example the third one is the program
design and the implementation that we
have seen a lot of money facing the
energy crisis in the last year and in
Germany for example the energy price cap
comes into place from today from the 1st
of March it's a great program but it's
not targeted so it's really uh everybody
gets it it's fine but it's not socially
inclusive and just for example so we
need targeted programs that's very
important and for example uh EU as a
role model it could be an idea to have
an energy poverty
um on an energy an Advisory Group for
example to invite all the experts what
we have to pull the expertise and the
knowledge and to
um to share it and uh for ex because
what we have seen for the European green
deal what is a great Flagship to keep
decarbonize our societies but we miss
gender it all in the European green deal
so it will not work without the gender
Dimension and finally a very concrete
recommendation is what we already have
in the renewable energy directive so
where we have included to protect the
vulnerable households the energy
communities so energy sharing for
example it's we have to transpose it
many some member states that did it
already like Spain and Netherlands and
Austria but Germany is lacking behind
unfortunately but here these energy
communities we also we can include
gender we can include social justice and
so to have also women as change agents
and prosumers
thank you very much and I'm looking
forward to the discussion
thank you very much Miss hubby's Bruner
for your presentation and to all of you
free for your inspiration
recommendations and ideas this is what
president Papa dimulos asked us to do so
we must deliver the Concrete Solutions
and you did so thank you very much for
that where with that I want to ask you
how you doing
you're still alive yes good I know
politicians are hesitant they they they
they wish to speak so my colleagues for
sure they are ready to start speaking
but you need to hold on because we have
two more uh distinguished
um experts who will take the floor and
then the floor is yours all yours so
um we make a little change over here in
the presidium
and then we continue with the meeting
thank you thank you very much
because yeah we will have comments and
questions to you
okay colleagues so we continue There was
30 seconds break for you and now uh we
continue against switching the Polish
we shall now listen to the presentation
of Mrs Juliana valgren director of
European anti-poverty Network she's
probably known to you
because the network
are there any comments
thank you very much colleagues so
the European Network since 2008 has been
campaigning on the energy poverty and
consumers in a vulnerable situation it
is now involved among others in the work
of working group on consumers in a
vulnerable situation which was
established by the European commission
and the Coalition rights to energy Mrs
wagran is the co-author of a handbook on
energy poverty and campaign for right to
energy to All European citizens Mrs
valgren the flow is yours 10 minutes for
you and thank you again for accepting
our invitation
hello good morning
um thank you European Parliament
um to distinguish MPS at the national
MPS and speakers thank you for this
invitation as mentioned before I
represent here the European anti-poverty
Network the APN is a network of networks
so we are network of 32 networks and
National level and 12 European
organizations working to tackle poverty
and social and exclusion
just to begin with my intervention I
would like to say when I talk about
women I'm going to talk about a woman as
in the concept of scenes gender but also
out to I'll talk about all those ex who
are expressing the agenda and
identifying themselves as women
um I would like also to start by saying
that poverty is a multi-dimensional
issue and affects uh all aspects of Life
simultaneously
however we as APN we Face a barrier to
better understand the concreting fact of
poverty in different groups too to the
lack of disaggregated data which is
already covered before and how we um
have not enough information on how
policies and practices mapped the
intersection of gender with multiple
um or intercessional inequalities
for us gender and poverty are
intertwined
um and therefore to have meaningful
policies
um the program should address both
perspectives at the same time and should
also understand the historical
inequalities impacting different
communities in the society just such as
lgbtiq age race ethnicity migrant
background and disability
but I'd like to bring us where we
navigate as APN and we try to fill the
gaps in the socio-economic
anti-discrimination and on energy
policies
what we know as APN is that European
Union member states all commit to this
principles
but more in a soft manner we don't see
very much hard compromise in that regard
and what we really strive for is for
Effective and structural change
so uh where do we stand as APN just that
you understand
um we try to bring
um more
um visibility to gender on social
policies we try to bring more uh
um the social economic aspect on gender
policies and then we try to fill the gap
of both of class socio-economic and
gender on energy policies so there is
here really an inconsistent approach and
there is really a loophole of an
intersection of Interest ratio
um
approach on these policies and just to
be more specific on how we try to
recenter gend gender and all the
characteristics on social policies how
to retry recent social economic
characteristics anti-discrimination as
such as an example the gender equality
strategy
um and how to resend agenda and
socioeconomic dynamations on energy
policies before I entered the aspect
mainly on gender poverty on energy I'll
try to bring some examples to make it
easier for you and to see how it works
so we're going to start with the gender
equality strategy uh in a chapter
traveling in a gender equal economy
saying that diversity equal
opportunities to thrive and be
economically independent equal pay equal
access to finance Fair patient and care
Share burden however there is a blind
spot there we talk about a lot of Labor
Market inclusion but we forget that
there is a lot of poverty for those
families and women who are working we
talk about the term of working in
poverty so how shall we include the
social dimension of poverty for those
who are ready including the label Market
but are still under the poverty line
another hope law in the gender equality
is the expectation
um as an ecology strategy is the
expectation to have Labor Market social
inclusion educational Dimensions
monitored by European semester and its
social support for those who don't know
the social School Board is a list of
indicators that measures the impact of
social policies however there is only
one indicator on gender which is the
employment gap we know that the eurobara
meta covers that but there is a lack of
alignment between the data from the
European semester and the social
scoreboard and the reference from the
Euro barometer so when it comes to
concrete measures to the member states
we see an absence a void of effective
measures that could be applied we also
face the same inconsistencies in Social
policies when it comes to the gender uh
blindness let's say like that just to
give you an example we just approved in
December the council recommendation for
minimal income and why I'm talking about
the social uh the the social aspect the
gender aspect on social economic
policies just to give an example of the
council recommendation we talk about a
lot about the question or the non-take
gaps for those who don't know what is
the concept of no take up no take up is
a phenomenon that represents the lack of
access to social protection and social
benefits and this is very important to
talk about because these are structure
measures that could be confined to
energy
urgent measures so when you have a big
percentage of the population for example
40 in Belgium they have not accept or
not adequate enough to have access to
social protection and they're already
under the poverty line and have no
restricted energy support for long-term
Solutions
we it's a it's a struggle that we have
to to to to combine all together so we
have to talk about energy crisis and
energy measures but we also have to take
a look at the social protection benefits
that are there and how people can
benefit and access them but let's go
back to the European green deal uh and
also the fit for 55 and where our
struggle is as APN because there is a
socio-economic blindness in the European
green deal and there is a gender
blindness in European union and we as
APN we try to navigate and bring more
um solutions for both aspects what is
important to mention is that
um when it comes to women or women-led
families that exposed to poverty in the
context of the energy crisis we have at
least free uh experience we have those
who are struggling to pay the bills or
to buy food
we have those who are struggling to
reduce consumption and then that's
leading to psychological and health
issues
and you have those who have not accessed
your funding scheme in that in their
constituencies so this is the reality of
many women and women-led families across
the European Union
and one of one of the problems what are
the how the how policies are responding
to that
um so what you have for example is that
um there is a lack of Target measures
for women and for poor families when it
comes to uh economic Income Support like
vouchers like subsides for bills they
are not targeting specific the needs of
women and families led by women
we don't have Target funding also same
there is a specific funding there is
Target for women living or at risk of
poverty
all the solutions are very Universal and
they are not targeting specific groups
with specific demands we are putting
more burdens on the consumers with low
income so this has a disproportional
impact and there is also a reflection
that we bring as APN it's going to be
impossible to combine the success or the
green transition if we continue with the
current uh immediate measures so
um we will not have the capacity with
the member state to address both the
needs of agreeing and effective
transition and the social social
protection at the same time but let's
move forward in terms of solutions
because we want to be constructive and
solution oriented and for us as
mentioned before the participation of
people experiencing poveraging this
process is very important they bring the
knowledge but also the expertise the
living expertise that they face in every
day's life
um more specific to the member State
because European green on the 5455 now
has a focus at the national level and
until June 2023 U.S member states you
have to present the new electricity and
climate plants and see how they are
adjusting to some uh electricity demands
and also some
um
Targets in terms of the energy crisis
would be great if you could prioritize
Target Investments and actions for
energy pool and women
but also when it comes to the rights of
a decent income we have now the minimum
income recommendation would be great to
see how member states are going to
transpose it but it's also important
that we ensure that all families and all
women have adequate social protection
benefits because they lead to structural
changes so if we can combine income
support for energy bills and energy
crisis with structural support coming
from social protection benefits we can
find at least a good solution in the
long term I also would like to call you
to reflect about a ban on these
connections
um I think as well we need to think
about all those families who are being
disconnected in the grid and it's really
important that we think about an
adequate income or an adequate amount of
foreign abuse of these people living in
energy poverty so thank you very much
thank you very much Miss valgren and
thank you for the constructive remarks
to our debate which we will launch
shortly but before that
the last speaker on my list is close
friend of our committee always present
here whenever we need her and her
agency Institute European Institute for
gender equality in Vilnius so the
lithuanians here must be very proud you
have this great Institute in your
country
I give you the floor director for
presenting your position on this
important topic and I want to thank you
in the name of the committee for all the
support you're providing to us and to
the member states you all probably have
worked with IGA on several occasions and
we all appreciate the I guess work so
once again thank you very much director
for being with us and I look forward to
hear you
thank you chair
and for your kind words it's it's always
a pleasure to be here and to work with
you
so Dear honorable members of the
European Parliament and National
parliaments and dear colleagues
it is with great pleasure and a
necessity that I'm here today to put an
issue up front and center
that is gripping the continent
many of us and I'm sure it also goes for
you but also for me
we go about our daily routine without
really thinking about it we just do it
we go through the daily routine every
day or less the same thing
but as we heard from my colleagues a lot
of people have to think about their
every single move literally every every
single move
because their every move comes at a cost
34 million Europeans were unable to
afford to keep their homes warm
and that's what we know from 2018
34 million can't hit their homes
properly
imagine now how many more are suffering
in times of dramatic inflation where
skyrocketing Energy prices leave money
questioning
can I afford to eat and heat at the same
time
basic human rights are being negotiated
and we heard it already but I'm going to
repeat again in the Fallout of energy
poverty certain households are more
vulnerable than others but talking about
energy poverty on a household level
well very relevant
the term household is still too abstract
and broader Concepts it obscures
important Dynamics
what does energy poverty look like past
the front door
we need some human context
who should be worried about
because not all members of a household
are equally affected by energy poverty
some spend more time at home
I guess evidence proves that women take
on the brunt of unpaid care compared to
men
from Child Care through to domestic care
meaning they spend more time at home
based on the general perception that
women are caregivers and to give you a
few data in 2020 women were twice as
likely as men to provide the bulk of
care for children under 12 years old and
unfortunately in 2020 the data are still
the same
one would think we would learn from the
crisis but we don't
also
what our evidence indicates is that in
times of Crisis is inequality worsens
alongside many others you have also
heard about the spikes of domestic
violence for example
women tend to have lower incomes due to
gender pay and pension gaps so energy
poverty and again I repeat what my
colleague said it's harder for women
because they simply do not earn as much
it's simple mathematics
single mothers mentioned before are
particularly exposed and I think it was
already mentioned but I would like to
say again that Euro found our sister
agency did a survey last spring
which focus on the ability to pay energy
bills and they found that close to 50
percent of the respondents who are
single mothers 50 of the single mothers
who responded
anticipate difficulties paying their
bills in the next three months imagine
this is probably not the full picture
it's incredible the lengths one will go
to pay a bill
I have heard of single mothers asking
their children to stay in libraries to
do their homework until closing time
because at home it's too expensive to
keep the lights on
remember I pensioned I mentioned pension
gaps earlier well
I've also heard of all the women staying
on buses longer to keep warm because
they cannot afford their heating bills
so I've given you a clear enough picture
and now it's time to turn to EU level
action
energy must be a guarantee to all
citizens as a basic right
but equally
given who I have highlighted amongst the
most vulnerable today we need to abduct
a gender lens to solving energy poverty
to ensure that the most vulnerable can
make it through the day knowing that
tomorrow is still possible
there are discussions on the way for a
social climate fund to provide financial
support to vulnerable households but no
agreement has been reached
lip service doesn't service anybody
political will and Active Solutions do
and we have to ensure that the solution
isn't at the expense of an existing
problem
which is only going to make things worse
for example
reducing the operating hours of
kindergarten as a way to save energy
swells the burden of Care for Women even
more
from a perspective of safety
switching off public lighting that is
chosen as a solution by many communities
switch off public lighting at night
could put women's safety in Jeopardy so
we have to think clearly also in a
gender sensitive way about possible
solutions
well again energy poverty affects
different groups of women and men very
differently so how then do you develop
tailored Solutions
I will give you an example with a three
steps forward approach because I like to
think positively because we can solve
this
step one
we need to eliminate deepening
inequalities for a fair and just
transition in energy and other areas
igis gender equality index which I hope
you all know
the general equality index measures the
progress of gender equality in the
European Union
at a member State NAU level we look at
six different domains
um we updated on a yearly basis and I
invite you to look at that index it
gives valuable information about your
country
um
it makes very clear at the country level
and also EU level
where the challenges lie and these
Solutions lie
and what I would like to say here is
that our Focus for this year's index
will be on the gender dimension of the
green deal
where we will be publishing evidence
related throughout the year
so that was step one
step two
energy poverty affects women and men not
households
the EU member states must collect gender
statistics to appreciate women and men's
different needs so in times of Crisis
the response is fit for each and every
purpose
step 3
resources are your recourse
igis gender mainstreaming tools are
abundant from assessments to budgeting
to monitoring and evaluation they are
ready to use and come with step-by-step
guidance and again I would like to
invite you to look at our website we
have a generation platform where you
find all the instruments that you would
need
to go through this process step to step
and to see where the challenges lie
so those were my three steps my three
proposals for Solutions in the future
and there is nothing stopping you
stopping us from starting now I look
forward to seeing it happen thank you
thank you director Sheila and I told you
she has a lot of expertise in her agency
thank you very much and thank you for
free steps approach which you proposed
the resources are very important also
for running I guess so we keep fingers
crossed for for that as well so
colleagues I give you five minutes break
to take coffee and tea which is outside
and then we come back
10 35 so you can you can have five
minutes break
thank you